My gym just increases prices.
So I got this new home wave home gym.
It has all these attachments.
This thing is basically a push up board
and you can put it in the different color coded spots
to condition in different areas,
like for chest
or for more shoulders or triceps or whatever.
So you have all these different options.
It also comes with a sheet
so you can see what exercises you can do.
And there's no fear when you're doing the exercises
because all the little carabiners have safety latches
so it's not gonna come undone.
It feels really safe and secure.
I am really excited to kind of
have my own little home gym set up
because I'm not trying to pay the prices for the gym
and I never have the time to make it.
If you want one for yourself,
the link is right here.
I highly recommend
and I absolutely love this thing.